wenn der Robert die Anna-Lena der
Christian und der Volker sich gerade
treffen dann haben sie offenbar
zuallererst mal eine richtig gute Zeit
[Musik]
und dann klingt es danach immer als
hätten sie gerade gemeinsam in Billy
Regal zusammengeschraubt die Schraube
schräg einsetzt dann wird sie nie wieder
gerade diese Schraube ist jedenfalls in
den ersten Tagen sehr gerade eingesetzt
worden Baumarkt der Politik und wir
schauen jetzt mal wie genau läuft das
denn gerade mit den Verhandlungen zur
Regierungsbildung beim sondieren testen
die Parteien also erstmal an mit wem
könnte es sich denn überhaupt lohnen
Koalitionsverhandlungen aufzunehmen da
geht es also erstmal um das
grundsätzliche nach dem Motto ja wir
waren politische Gegner aber können wir
uns vorstellen dass wir trotzdem
irgendwie miteinander können wir gucken
uns heute mal an welches Bündnis die
besten Chancen hat wie man in der
Politik überhaupt richtig verhandelt und
was man aus dem Jamaika Scheitern von
2017 lernen kann und jetzt geht's los
wer kann mit wem und wer kann mit wem
gar nicht Lindner ist ein Luftikus hat
Kevin Kühnert das ist der Jungs da der
SPD noch kurz vor der Wahl gesagt tja
und jetzt müssen SPD und FDP auch wieder
zusammen am Tisch sitzen während Claudia
Roth von den Grünen und die FDP-Frau
streikt Zimmermann sich im Fernsehen
schon die ghettofaust geben und sagen
wenn wir beide regieren dann
legalisieren wir auf jeden Fall Cannabis
sofort Cannabis freigegeben
ja aber bei diesen Verhandlungen steht
natürlich mehr auf dem Spiel als die
Zukunft von Cannabis und deswegen habe
ich mir einen echten
verhandlungsexperten an die Seite geholt
nämlich Jack Nasher und der weiß alles
über die richtige Taktik bei solchen
schwierigen politischen Gesprächen muss
man sich mögen um zu guten Ergebnisse zu
kommen überhaupt nicht man muss sie
nicht mögen man muss sich nur
respektieren und gerade Politiker wissen
das weil da wird natürlich immer im
Wahlkampf wird auch mit sehr harten
Bandagen gespielt danach sitzt man
zusammen so ist das halt ja Hauptsache
man schafft es Vertrauen aufzubauen in
diesen allerersten Gesprächen und
Vertraulichkeit auch ganz wichtig
[Musik]
mit diesem selfie HIER Ihr habt alle
gesehen könnte tatsächlich was ganz
Neues beginnen bärbock und Habeck
Wissing und Lindner treffen sich zum
allerersten Mal und zwar ohne vorher die
Presse zu informieren Frechheit und
Posten danach alle das gleiche Foto da
steckt natürlich ganz viel message drin
erstens wir können dicht halten zweitens
ohne uns geht hier gar nichts mehr und
drittens wir erfinden das Format
politischer Gespräche ganz neu und bei
der ersten Pressekonferenz danach war
ich auch vor Ort und habe gefragt wie
geht das mit dem sondieren können Sie
mal ein bisschen sagen wie sie taktisch
davor gehen in diesen Gesprächen fangen
sie an mit den Themen wo sie eh eher
sowieso schon nah beieinander sind wo es
einfacher ist und lassen die schwierigen
Themen wie Steuerpolitik erst für den
ganz für den Schluss oder wie wie geht
man davor wir sind heute schmallig auch
dazu können wir heute nichts weiteres
sagen what ihr gebt eine Pressekonferenz
und könnt danach nichts sagen dasselbe
kam danach in Varianten noch mehrfach
dazu möchten wir nicht sagen wir haben
sehr vertrauensvolle Gespräche und zum
gemeinsamen Prozess gehört eben auch
dass wir nicht fortwährend
Zwischenergebnisse und
Wasserstandsmeldungen nach draußen geben
so haben wir uns auch vereinbart und
daran werden wir drei uns vor allem
halten ja und der verhandlungsprofi Jack
Nasher sagt genau so geht's es ist
unheimlich wichtig weil wenn wir
Publikum haben in Verhandlungen werden
wir viel aggressiver das heißt wenn die
ganze Zeit Leute gucken dann wird es
sehr sehr schwierig wenn ich die ganze
Zeit sage wo die Verhandlungsposition
ist auf keinen Fall und das empfehle ich
den wirklich halte die Klappe sagt es
nicht weil dass euch viel viel schwächer
macht in der Verhandlung weil dann müsst
ihr immer noch dass euren anderen den
anderen verkaufen der Öffentlichkeit
verkaufen und das macht die Verhandlung
fast unmöglich der Grund ist klar allen
steckt noch dieses 2017 in den Knochen
alles soll diesmal anders besser laufen
als bei diesen jämmerlich gescheiterten
jamaika-verhandlungen da war nämlich
nichts mit Vertraulichkeit
[Musik]
damals trafen sich Union FDP und Grüne
über 50 Tage lang in der noblen
parlamentarischen Vertretung direkt
gegenüber vom Bundestag und hier in
diesem Raum mit den weißen schweren
Tischdecken wurden dann die langen lange
Listen mit Forderungen der einzelnen
Parteien Punkt für Punkt abgearbeitet
die balkonpausen waren legendär da wurde
für die Fotografen immer draußen Friede
Freude Eierkuchen inszeniert was das
Zeug hält und wir Journalisten wir
standen draußen in der Kälte stundenlang
ab und zu kam eine SMS von einem
Pressesprecher oder einem Politiker oder
hieß es dann also dies und jenes ist
jetzt geeint aber dies und das ist noch
strittig das ging oft bis tief in die
Nacht und am Ende als immer noch 237
Punkte offen waren da schmilzt Christian
Lindner hin es ist besser nicht zu
regieren als falsch zu regieren wer
damals auch stinksauer war er hier das
war ein ganz fürchterlicher Tag den will
man nicht noch mal erleben über viele
viele Stunden in kleinen Gruppen in
großen Gruppen hin Papiere gemacht eine
ganz angespannte Atmosphäre und das
hätte eigentlich zu jeder Zeit scheitern
können aber als man dann durch war
jedenfalls ich das Gefühl hatte so jetzt
haben wir ein Paket geschnürt
das kann tragen wird das Paket gar nicht
mehr verhandelt sondern dann wird der
Stecker gezogen und da habe ich schon
gedacht hey
verkackeiern kann ich mich alleine ja
also von Christian Lindner weiß man also
das ist einer der steht notfalls auch
auf und geht ich glaube das stimmt nicht
mehr vier Jahre später muss die FDP
regieren das kann Christian Lindner
seinen eigenen Leuten nicht noch mal
erklären dass er davon laufen würde und
das wissen natürlich seine
Verhandlungspartner heute auch nur für
einen ist er wirklich die letzte
Hoffnung
[Musik]
der Bundesvorstand das Präsidium
der CDU ist sich darin einig dass wir zu
Gesprächen für eine sogenannte
Jamaika-Koalition bereitstehen für Armin
Laschet ist Jamaika die letzte Chance
kommt das nicht geht er quasi in Rente
und die Union in die Opposition heißt
Laschet ist erpressbar mit ihm hätten
FDP und Grüne wirklich leichtes Spiel
denn die Union hat Bittsteller Status in
diesen Sondierungen das kann man nach
den ersten Gesprächen ganz gut raushören
das war ein guter Abend das war ein
guter Start der Lust auf mehr macht
heute war es ein Gespräch das wirklich
von großer Vertraulichkeit geprägt war
aber auch von großen inhaltlichen
Schnittmengen aber die Mehrheit der
Wähler will gar keinen Jamaika Bündnis
und bei FDP und Grünen ist man total
irritiert darüber wie angezählt Armin
Laschet aus den eigenen Reihen gerade
ist ich glaube ja Christian Lindner hält
die jamaika-optionen nur deswegen noch
so ein bisschen in der Schwebe um einen
Druckmittel zu haben gegenüber der
Ampelkoalition
so ein bisschen Druck gehört ja auch
dazu sagt Jack Nasher wenn ich richtig
droh dann mache ich das so dann sage ich
hey ich will gerne lass uns das zusammen
hinbekommen weil sonst müssen wir leider
ich habe Druck eben aus den eigenen
Reihen dass wir dann was anderes machen
wie zum Beispiel die große Koalition
oder Neuwahlen oder was auch immer oder
wir gehen in die Opposition machen und
sage möglich aber das ist eben wichtig
dass ich sehr wohl Alternativen habe und
die auch klar kommuniziere aber
freundlich eben nicht drohen
[Musik]
für die dagegen ganz selbstbewusst auf
kanzlerkurs wir sind da klar wir wollen
Olaf Scholz als Kanzler die
Sozialdemokraten wollen noch im Oktober
mit Koalitionsgesprächen beginnen und
stellen in Aussicht dass die
ampelregierung bis Weihnachten steht das
klingt jetzt so easy aber auch das wird
nicht einfach selbst zwischen den
Wunschpartnern SPD und Grüne gibt es
große inhaltliche Differenzen denkt noch
mal an den Kohleausstieg 2038 das ist
den Grünen viel zu spät und der Weg von
der SPD zur FDP der ist noch viel weiter
Beispiel Finanzen natürlich
war auch klar dass unsere inhaltlichen
Positionierungen in wesentlichen Punkten
auseinander liegen ja und genau da kommt
es eben auf das richtige verhandeln an
[Musik]
interessant ist ja bei so
Verhandlungsdelegationen immer wie bei
einer guten Party wer bringt wen mit und
in diesem Fall ist es so die SPD kommt
mit sechs Leuten FDP grüne CDU bringen
jeweils 10 mit und die CSU bringt
natürlich auch noch mal fünf Leute mit
obwohl eigentlich alle wissen dass es
gar keine gute Idee ist wenn so viele
mitreden waren nicht alle dabei aber die
die dabei waren wissen dass große Teams
nicht zu einer besonderen Stärke geführt
haben und trotzdem machen sie den
gleichen Fehler wieder das heißt für
eine Ampel würden also 26 Leute
verhandeln und für Jamaika sogar
sagenhafte 35 also eine gute Größe sind
pro Team drei bis fünf Leute empfehle
ich immer weil sonst gibt es zu viel
verschiedene Interessen und wenn zu
viele sind muss ganz klar sein wer
Verhandlungsführer ist wer beobachtet
und wer bad cop ist die Rollen müssen
sehr klar verteilt sein so
räumenverteilung die SPD bringt zum
Beispiel Malu Dreyer mit nach Berlin an
den Verhandlungstisch da fragt man sich
jetzt vielleicht erstmal wieso das denn
was macht sie denn da naja das hat ein
Grund Malu Dreyer ist die
rheinland-pfälzische Ministerpräsidentin
die hat schon 2017 in ihrem Land ein
ampelbündnis erfolgreich geschmiedet und
ein grüner der damals dabei war der hat
mir mal erzählt wie das lief angeblich
hat die SPD zuerst bei den klimatemen
die FDP gegen die Grünen ausgespielt und
dann hat sie sich bei den fdp-themen mit
den Grünen verbündet das heißt Malu
Dreyer weiß offensichtlich sehr genau
wie dieses Schachspiel Verhandlungen
funktioniert und deswegen ist sie jetzt
in Berlin dabei aber FDP und Grüne haben
aus solchen Situationen natürlich auch
gelernt deshalb jetzt auch all diese
Vorgespräche immer wieder die Betonung
dass man zusammen stärker sei als Union
und SPD und ganz wichtig auch Brücken
suchen
ein guter Verhandler sucht immer erstmal
das Verbindende die Brücken von denen
jetzt immer wieder die Rede ist und baut
dann darauf auf also Brücken statt
gleich rote Linien ziehen und für jede
Partei muss am Ende was rausspringen für
die eigene Wähler Klientel irgendwas
muss im Koalitionsvertrag sich finden wo
jede Partei sagen kann das steht da nur
weil wir es wollten also ich muss als
Verhandler sozusagen immer die Victory
speech der anderen schreiben ich muss
mir immer überlegen wie kann sie jetzt
vor ihre Wähler treten und stolz
verkünden was sie alles geschafft hat
und das ist das A und O also ich muss
immer liegen wie kann sie es verkaufen
und diese Argumente muss ich ihr mit an
die Hand geben das könnte bei der Ampel
dann zum Beispiel so aussehen die SPD
kriegt ihre 12 € Mindestlohn für die FDP
einigen sich alle darauf dass die
Schuldenbremse eingehalten wird und die
Grünen setzen durch das solar- und
Windkraft schneller ausgebaut werden so
wird glaube ich gerade auch geredet dass
die Sachen nicht durchgestochen werden
dass man ernsthaft ringt dass man auch
versucht mitzudenken was ist denn das
Projekt des jeweils anderen und wie kann
man daraus vielleicht
gemeinsame Erzählung machen hört sich
für mich erstmal sehr gut an und jetzt
fragt ihr euch vielleicht wie will denn
Christian Lindner seinen Wählern
erklären dass die versprochene
Steuerentlastung nicht sofort kommt ganz
einfach Lindner deutet jetzt schon an
das müsste ja nicht alles sofort kommen
wichtig sei dass man jetzt in ein
entlastungs Jahrzehnt gehe das heißt
also nichts anderes als die FDP streckt
einfach ihr wahlversprechend ein
bisschen ja das sind so die Strategien
und zwei Sachen sind noch wichtig zum
einen stundenlange Nachtsitzungen
verhandeln bis einer vor Erschöpfung
einschläft dass wir keiner mehr und das
bringt auch gar nichts und über posten
sollte man erst ganz zum Schluss reden
erst das Land dann die Partei dann die
Person in der Reihenfolge das heißt wer
Finanzminister wird darüber müsst ihr
euch später streiten Christian und
Robert okay
[Musik]
also dann schauen wir mal was Sie sich
für eine Regierung für uns zurecht
verhandeln wenn ihr politisch
interessiert seid dann haben wir weitere
tolle Videos für euch bei
inside-politics empfehlt uns weiter
abonniert uns liked uns und wenn ihr
Fragen habt schreibt gerne unten in die
Kommentare